[Applause]
if bob knew a documentary was being made
about him he would act like he didn't
like it and he would love every minute
of it hey
guys i think you'd get a kick out of the
fact that i have to sit here and do this
knowing that i really don't want to i
think he would love it and i think he
would
want to be in it mostly by himself
[Laughter]
there was my brother cliff bob and
myself nobody thought bob was going to
be any kind of an entertainer did you
stick a gerbil up your ass who told you
that it's not important no of course i
ain't sticking you i'm so upset from
smothers brothers comedy hour we were as
close as two people could be being a guy
who loves physical comedy super dave was
must watch tv for me growing up
[Music]
watch the bag
sure holy
i was obsessed with him instantly he was
always very dry he mixed these corny old
jokes with his weird angry approach the
straight man's usually what the funny
man bounces off of but he's both did you
take the flowers at my mother's site
there's so many of them because i didn't
know without you you know many of them
is that such a doctor to pick
if you're lucky enough to have a thing
that works jerry marty funkhouse hey
marty how you doing that's your thing
you don't need more than one thing he is
a big personality but a big love it was
bob's world we're only living in it
[Music]
you